That's the sound of Hong Kong residents
booing the Chinese national anthem
as it plays before a soccer match on a Tuesday night, which is an illegal act in mainland China.
After more than three months of sustained protests, nobody seems quite sure what will happen next.
But the protestors we talked to on the march to the soccer stadium
were clear that the government's formal withdrawal of the controversial extradition bill
that sparked the protests to begin with, wouldn't be enough.
The protestors say that their police force has lost public trust,
and that their government is hopelessly compromised,
it's leaders controlled by the Chinese Communist Party.
They want an independent investigation into the police. And they want to elect their own leaders,
rather than having them selected by interest groups that they view as beholden to mainland China.
The Hong Kong government is obviously controlled totally by the communist government.
So that is something that has serviced
within these three months of protests.
Where we have seen Carrie Lam really
having her hands tied, we have a chief executive
who is only responding to the requests of the Beijing government.
Imagery of protesters holding American
flags while marching outside the U.S. consulate
has made its way into international press coverage.
And while there weren't any stars and stripes present at Tuesday night's march,
participants did have a message for Americans.
Protestors expressed hope
that the U.S. Congress would pass the Hong Kong Human Rights and Democracy Act,
which would make the city's bilateral trade and travel agreements with America
contingent on China maintaining Hong Kong's autonomy,
and levy sanctions against Chinese individuals accused of violating the rights of Hong Kong citizens.
It would also instruct U.S. immigration officials not to punish visa applicants
who've been arrested for participating in the protests.
Hong Kong's soccer team lost the match, but for many in this crowd, tonight was about more than just a game.